this is the problem with college and is  that they teach you the theoretical side  of everything  for the person that's working for you  but it doesn't teach you to be the ceo  the practical side and the young  entrepreneur whether you're trying to go  up the corporate ladder or you are doing  it you're on and it's just the simple  things of and these are some of my great  tillmanisms from the book and why  harpercollins came to me and asked me to  write this book was  know your numbers okay you've got to  know your numbers there are no spare  customers we're all in a consumer  business you people watching this  podcast for you or me serving casino  customers restaurant customers hotel  customers there are no spare customers  we're all after the same consumer to the  95 5 rule that 95 percent of everything  is right so look for the five percent  that's wrong